they say that we have leftover evolution
and all its struggles but landed in a
world of slow and as our bodies begin to
mirror our lives they slow too as to our
minds
the ideas stop flowing we stopped so
they say perhaps they're right but I say
not I say this is the calm before the
storm I say this is the quiet breath we
take before we step out proud of who we
are that we are a force with such
momentum that together we can only move
forwards and in that direction there is
no wrong for whilst we may be slow may
be happy
focus
free
maybe Big B school be still
be fast
move as one
if you would evolve into something more
be active